of course with the film it comes your
own little yeah yeah and I actually I
actually have they've there you go
and they're actually done one of you as
well which is they so there's
[Applause]
I'm told I finished
I can trade you have like a collection
of versions of you that have been made
and brought as gift is that there are
some other right toys of me at home
everything I know there was a lot of
details fully accessorized I really
actually it's done very well I really I
worked very hard on it
I'm very very impressed but now Brazil
so I'm showing you you're sorry I threw
you away but presumably you know some
people must be very excited like me when
they see a figure of themselves but you
right I mean yeah the director actually
sent me a very well-meaning text well of
all the like the toys and stuff that
they've got lined up to come out when
the film comes out and he was just like
congratulations you're a toy and I'm
like I've bit I mean I don't want to
rain on your thing I've just been a toy
a lot like a Barry conceited but it's
not meant that way it's just a weird
reactive of all the people he could have
texted I've been seeing myself as weird
plastic figures
[Laughter]
[Music]
you